il n'y a qu'une seule vraie question
jurés vous sur votre vie
que vous dites la vérité
mon père me prédisait une puis heureuse
je me suis marié
j'étais pas des pouces
pgt juger et milliers pas remplies
[Applaudissements]
je la firme ici devant vous
je n'ai jamais dit que la vérité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la plus épouvantable des accusations a
été formulée contre nous
jacques le gris est entré chez nous
il m'a agressé
l'accusation force
je dis la vérité
la vérité n'a aucune importance seul de
pouvoir des hommes comptent
le faire doit être réglé dans le cas je
suis innocent
j'aurais que la madeleine judiciaire si
vous perdez votre femme en subira les
graves conséquences
l'un de nous deux a menti mais son dieu
en décider
vous ne me croyez pas
je risque ma vie pour vous il faut
risquer ma vie pour sauver votre
réputation
le châtiment
pour faux témoignage
et le bûcher vous serez
brûlées vives
se refuse de me taire
[Musique]